dans l'actu aujourd'hui l'Open de France
de golf c'est terminé ce dimanche à
Guyancourt par la victoire d'un Allemand
Marcel SIM c'est sa deuxième victoire
sur le circuit européen le meilleur
Français Raphaël Jacquelin termine 3e à
deux coups du vainqueur la guérilla
jardinière le nom peut faire peur en
réalité il s'agit pour un collectif de
se réapproprier l'espace urbain et d'y
ajouter des éléments de verdure une note
de verre au milieu du béton le soleil
tarde à venir et pourtant il faut penser
en cette saison à prévenir ses yeux des
ultraviolets les conseils d'un
ophtalmologiste la seule protection ce
sont les verres solaires il faut bien
les choisir RTT une signification qui
peut en cacher une autre RTT comme
remettait tong une série d'animations
proposées à Magny-les-Hameaux troisième
édition qui se termine ce vendredi soir
la 96e édition de l'Open de golf s'est
refermé dimanche sur la victoire de
l'Allemand Marcel SIM une victoire sur
le fil il devance d'un coup seulement
l'italien en Francisco Molinari un coup
à 525000 euros c'est la somme touchée
par le vainqueur cette année Marcel 6
mais 14e ou 15e à la monnaie le joueur
rnstenson est 13e donc non il y a pas de
surprise il y a un peu de déception avec
Raphaël qui a été pendant quelques trous
en tête
le nouveau numéro 1 français Raphaël
Jacquelin termine sur la dernière marche
du podium avec seulement deux points de
retard le public était venu nombreux à
bord du parcours de l'Albatros pour le
soutenir vous suivez quel joueur en
particulier aujourd'hui
je suis Jacquelin pourquoi lui parce que
d'abord c'est un très bon joueur et
qu'il est très sympathique voilà et
qu'il y a une un enthousiasme derrière
lui qui est porteur Lopez cette année
n'aura pas été épargné par les mauvaises
conditions météo malgré tout le bilan
reste positif
aujourd'hui on doit avoir entre 10 et
12000 spectateurs c'est moins bien que
les 14 ou 16000 qu'on a eu l'année
dernière mais il faut rappeler que
l'année dernière on avait un Français
qui était en tête Thomas Levet et il
faisait ciel bleu si elle bleu ciel bleu
et aujourd'hui plutôt beaucoup de nuages
un gros gros orage cette nuit pluie ce
matin c'est encourage pas les golfeurs
habitués même s'ils sont passionnés de
golf à venir plus de 500 personnes
mobilisées côté organisation un Open qui
monte en puissance avant d'accueillir la
Ryder Cup en 2018 d'ici là rendez-vous
le 4 juillet 2013 avec peut-être une
victoire française ce serait la
cinquième seulement en plus de 40 ans
on a organisé une journée de
réappropriation de l'espace public donc
le but c'était de réaliser différentes
actions des actions comme là on est en
train de le faire de guérilla gardening
donc pour végétaliser la ville donc là
c'est des actions à long terme parce
qu'on va pas se contenter de semer comme
ça et puis de plus revenir ça demande un
peu de suivi la guérilla jardinière une
action directe qui consiste à planter et
se met dans l'espace public une pratique
qui nous vient du Japon directement
inspirée par la permaculture
permaculture ça consiste à faire de
l'agriculture en intervenant le moins
possible sur la nature en laissant la
nature prendre le dessus et ne par
exemple ne pas retourner la terre et
compagnie étant donné que notre plus en
plus de béton dans la ville et voilà
donc c'est plus sympa d'avoir des fleurs
des plans et c'est aussi le côté de se
dire qu'on a ce qu'il faut en fait pour
manger à porter demain quoi si on a des
abris fruitiers objectifs esthétique
écologique et donc pratique ce jour-là
le crêpe avait également organisé une
balade citoyenne pour promouvoir les
transports non polluants nom de code
vélo ruption
une initiative suivie d'un repas partagé
deux débats et d’intervention politique
du collectif Vélodrome contre
l'implantation du Vélodrome à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il s'agissait
de la deuxième journée de ce type
organisé sur l'agglomération le CREP de
50 ans en Yvelines espère bien
mensualiser l'initiative dès septembre
prochain
pas beaucoup de soleil en ce moment et
pourtant il faut penser à protéger ses
yeux des rayons des ultraviolets UVA et
UVB qui peuvent donner un certain nombre
de lésions au niveau de la paroi
oculaire avoir des lésions cela ne fait
pas mal d'où l'importance de la
prévention surtout pour les enfants de
moins de 12 ans et les personnes âgées
qui doivent se protéger la seule
solution mettre des lunettes de soleil
mais pas n'importe lesquels il faut
systématiquement les acheter chez un
opticien il faut surtout pas acheter des
verres solaires qui sont des Verget qui
sont appelés des vers solaires qui sont
des Verget qu'on peut acheter dans les
prises uniques ou sur les marchés ou sur
internet faut savoir que ça ça ne
protège en rien c'est des vers qui sont
simplement teintés donc qui vont jouer
sur l'éblouissement mais ça n'arrête en
rien les ultraviolets et quand vous vous
trouverez chez ce professionnel
attention à bien choisir vos verres
solaires il faut qu'il soit polarisé il
faut savoir que quand vous avez une
lumière qui arrive sur une surface plane
cette lumière va provoquer va se
polariser et ça va provoquer construire
une réverbération et des reflets qui
pour le pour l'individu donne un
éblouissement une baisse de une baisse
de vision une baisse d'acuité visuelle
et le fait que le verre soit polarisé ça
permet
à l'oeil de recevoir que la lumière qui
apporte une information visuelle c'est à
dire que le verbe polarisé fonctionne un
peu comme un store vénitien si vous
voulez il faut également bien choisir
son indice dit indice de réfraction qui
va de 0 à 4 disons que 0 1 et 2 c'est
des verres qui sont peu teintés et qui
qui servent essentiellement pour le
soleil qu'on peut avoir sur la région
parisienne
lundi 3 c'est l'indice qui est le plus
fréquemment utilisé qu'on utilise à la
plage ou dans des pays où il y a
beaucoup de soleil et l'indice 4 c'est
vraiment la ce qu'on utilise à l'heure à
la neige ou dans les verres ou alors si
vous allez vraiment dans des pays où il
y a énormément énormément de soleil
enfin la teinte des verres a également
son importance choisir une teinte grise
si vous êtes hypermétrope et une teinte
brune si vous êtes myope
et tout ce qu'on a envie de faire et ce
n'est pas fini remettez compte c'est
encore mardi soir avec un concert et du
cinéma en plein air vendredi prochain
l'opération se termine par un grand bal
suivi d'un feu d'artifice cette fête de
l'été coïncidait aussi avec la fin des
travaux de réhabilitation des espaces
publics et des parkings du quartier du
Buisson une exposition de photos
rappelait l'avant et l'après